anti-growth said only the paranoids
survive have you ever made a decision in
life where you did not see the benefits
or the consequences of it for year two
years three years well China as a
country made a decision in 1979 that
they're seeing the consequences of it
and it's a very very painful we're going
to talk about that today
[Music]
from this video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel let's get right
into it so what is this one policy they
came up with in 1979 that changed the
game before I show this to you I want to
explain a couple things number one if I
ask you right now what is the fastest
growing social media platform in America
and the world and I've told you which
former Behemoth social media platform is
getting slower and people are no longer
joining it what would you say you
probably said the first one as Tick Tock
right and you probably said Facebook
matter of fact if I were to ask you
right now how often do you log on to
Facebook if you said every day odds are
you're about 40 years old if you said I
don't ever go on Tick Tock odds are you
about 40 years old if you sit I'm on
Tick Tock every day you're probably
between 18 to 34 years old here's a
numbers matter of fact according to
statista average of population on Tick
Tock versus Facebook ages 18 to 34
here's what it looks like for Facebook
51.5 percent of face Facebook's
population is 18-34 but for tick tock
ready
71.3 percent whoever gets the young
population will continue to grow year
over year over year right now Tick Tock
has a young Guardians Facebook has an
aging audience that's kind of going away
so let's look at China 1979 is when they
came out with the one child policy to
control population growth and there's
this one great chart that they show with
data where if you look at this chart
it's been set a growing economy a
healthy country is one that looks like a
triangle and one that's a dying
population is one that is looking like
an inverted pyramid so if you look at
these three here's what you'll notice
the one furthest to the left is China in
1990 so what does that mean the blue and
the pink the blue is male population the
pinkiest female population and if you
look at the chart to the left it'll show
you zero to four five to nine years old
10 to 14 years old 15 to 20. you see the
idea it's shown which one is the biggest
and it looks like a healthy triangle
meaning China at that point had more
kids Young younger population and their
aging population was smaller then you go
to 2014 look what happens there then you
go to 2025 is what they're predicting
look what that looks like and they go to
2050 if they go the way they're going
right now this is not good news for them
they're no longer young they're getting
older so what does this really mean
let's go into a little bit deeper to see
why this is a big issue so why do you do
this part why did they come up with this
one child policy because in 1950 the
population started getting so big that
they didn't have enough food supply they
said listen we got to figure this thing
out we are way too big we don't have
enough food we got to do something about
this brilliant idea one child policy at
least at the point they thought it was a
good policy and that's kind of what
turned into what it is today so let's
look at this chart when it comes on to
life expectancy if you look at this you
get the blue at the top you got the
green at the bottom if you look at the
top left it says life expectancy from
birth years if you look at the bottom
left that's the green that's annual
percentage change so let's focus on the
top in 1964 the life expectancy in China
was roughly 46.7 years old so you lived
at around 40 six and a half you died
from 1964 to current that went from
46.73 to today it's 77 years old their
life expectancy increased 30 years
matter of fact if we divide 30 by 46
their life expectancy grew by nearly 70
percent in a span of 30 years so now the
country's sitting there saying how the
hell are we going to handle this even in
one year life expectancy went up five
percent this is a concern so how are you
trying to get here well in 1971 you know
the one thing that Nixon gets a lot of
credit for is to opening up the relation
with China with the help of Henry
Kissinger to their going out there
things are looking a little bit smooth
what about if we do this what about if
we do that all of a sudden 1978 China
says after years of control they finally
implemented a major program of economic
reform it encouraged Private Business
foreign trade and investment relaxed
State control over prices and invested
in industrial production and the
education of its Workforce so what did
this do they went from growing in 1978
at six percent their economy to nine
percent according to Brookings Institute
well when this happens there's a big
difference between six percent and nine
percent that's a fifty percent growth
they got to start looking at some things
there right so if you look at
historically what they did in 1990
December Shanghai stock market reopens
for the first time since 1949 and then
eventually in the late 90s early 2000s
they joined WTO World Trade Organization
so now everybody around the world wants
to do business with China so let's look
at Chinese as fertility rate what
happened over the years were they having
a lot of kids before and how bad was it
when they said only one child policy can
they really stop everybody in China from
having sex here's what it looks like in
1950 the average woman was having around
six kids and it stayed at that number
till about the late 60s then it dropped
off from 1970 at six all the way down to
three in 1978 and it gradually kept
going down and down and down until it
was around one and a half from 1995 till
today so you may be looking at the same
so what pad people stopped having babies
I mean you know they're already having
one and a half billion people they had a
billion people what's the big deal if
people stopped having babies well this
to the four problem that they talk about
what is that each child now is
responsible for taking care of two aging
parents and four aging grandparents
culturally that's what you got to do
it's like man I don't have that kind of
money how can I go out there and take
care of all these guys on top of that
parents wanted to start having boys not
girls
so gradually because boys can help with
the businesses right that's kind of how
they viewed it gradually when you think
about population for every one girl
there's one boy right that's kind of
what we are so in China it kept going
higher and higher and higher where there
were years where was 110 males for every
100 female 10 higher because they were
leaning towards that well that's a
problem as well there's a lot of times
you hear about you'll read about that
women are sitting there and say well I
want to pick and choose what man I want
to be with because there's more men than
women that's one of the challenges that
they're seeing in China today so we get
the idea some people say well Pat give
me a break I get what you're saying here
okay fine 110 per 100 fine their
Workforce has gotten bigger year over
year over year you're right up until
2014 2015. here's what it looked like if
you look at it from 2000 that's 739
million people working it kept going up
up to 760 to 770 to 780 all the way up
to 800 in 2015 and then what do they see
every year it keeps going lower and
lower and lower or why because aging
population is retiring they don't want
to work anymore and they're not having
enough kids so the younger populations
having to do double the work because
there's not enough of them to sustain
and take care of everybody this is a
major issue so what happens when there's
an agent population what do they need to
think about it they need what Social
Security someone's got to take care of
return my God I didn't save any money
how do I eat health care I need to go
see the doctor things are no longer
working the way they did my body is
breaking down right Med South Med
Advantage you know Health Care
prescription so that's expensive who's
going to pay for that taxes so if you
look at this you may say well it could
be okay if they're having more newborn
zero to four than people that are above
60 so if as long as that's bigger than
the other we should be okay look at this
chart here on what it's looking like
comparing newborns to four years old new
kids being born versus the population of
60 plus this is deeply concerning take a
look at this 1950 if you look at that
till
1995. every year they had a bigger
population ages zero to four than they
did 60 until around 1995 then look what
happened to it by now the elderly people
in China quarter of a billion people and
climbing while the zero to four is
declining who the hell is going to take
care of these folks who would what kind
of money with what kind of wealth how
they gonna handle this and by the way
they've been trying to keep this a
secret for a while because just in 2020
China finally begrudgiantly admitted
that they over count it they their
younger population by a hundred million
people 100 million then the world's like
wait a minute you're not as young as you
told us you are you were not reporting
these numbers right damn if this is the
case you're in trouble people are not
starting to figure it out Pat this is
this is a lot of fear-mongering because
look if you really want to say that this
has happened show us some of the health
expenditure because you can't tell us
this has happened and their health
expenditure is not really going higher
here's a chart that's going to validate
this from 2001 till today look at this
this is in billion one eight trillion is
what they have to spend last year just
20 years ago it was a little over half a
trillion a year to now eight trillion
and 20 years let me unpack this for you
this means it used to take you
seventy five thousand dollars a year of
expenses to take care of yourself 20
years ago and you know what it is today
today you have to do I don't know 1.2
million dollars per year in 20 years how
you gonna do that that that's that's a
lot of pressure in a nation that China
is currently having to solve that's a
big problem they have as well so now you
may say well Pat you know pick on
somebody your own size you know China
you compare them to smaller countries
why don't you compare China with
somebody that's on sites such as India
no problem so China used to be the
biggest population in the world India
just passed them up just recently this
is not like happened 20 years ago this
is recent the last year or so passed
them up but when you look at China's
population above 65 years old China has
166 million people above 65. you know
what India is above 65 years old only 84
million okay that's what India's Got and
India is Young their average age I
believe is around 26 to 28 years old the
average age the population in China is
around 38.4 years old that's a big
number right there so yes even if we
pick somebody their own size India is
Young China is old there's a reason why
these guys cannot stand each other and
India just blocked over a hundred apps
from China China if there is a country
they may hate as much as they hate
America and they keep it to themselves
and they don't publicly advertise well
sometimes they do publicly advertise it
they hate India because they fear India
because India is Young and they're
getting old so so what happens to us
when we're getting gold guys we get
older we don't spend as much money as we
did when we were younger younger we want
to kind of buy and impress people you
get older I'm not really too worried
about it so what's the problem with this
well today household consumption
accounts for around 37 to 38 percent in
China okay this is according to the
National Bureau of Statistics of China
which means they're having to rely on
Outsiders to buy their stuff like
America and other countries and this 37
38 number that I just gave used to be 68
in 1980 they relied on themselves they
can't do that anymore now they need you
and I now they need other countries tree
so that is problematic for a country
like China because if other people don't
buy their customers they're going to
take a massive hit like well listen look
at America we got 40 million immigrants
at least America's got all these
immigrants coming I'm sure China's been
crushing with immigration who wouldn't
want to go to China see all these big
buildings see all these things they're
doing they got to be crushing it with
migration right what if I told you since
1950 till today China's net migration
rate has been in the negative they've
never been in the positive the only
thing is people want to escape that
place no one's trying to go to China
they're trying to leave China people are
trying to come to America ain't nobody
trying to leave America at least not
till today right if it wasn't for
migration in America we would also be in
the negative but we get other people
immigrants that want to come here like
this guy like some of you maybe so these
numbers when you look at China's net
migration rate versus U.S we've always
been into positive since 1950 and matter
of fact since 1970 we've been at three
percent every year as high as six
percent at times because everybody wants
to take advantage of the American dream
Millions want to do that every year like
I don't have any more data I can pull a
bunch of different things to show you
but it's like beating a dead horse right
now I think it's fair to say she is
probably not going to like this post
this video we're not going to get a
thumbs up probably Yao Ming's not gonna
probably Jackie Chan's not gonna like
this video I think he's going to be
probably upset about this so what's the
point about this whole thing to to have
a a population a country girl you need
to average around 2.1 child per woman
born right China right now is around 1.1
we covered that part already but what
does all this stuff really mean I mean
look G stands they're very confidently
around everybody else he doesn't look
like he's concerned he's broken deals
with Putin they look very confident
talking about the next hundred years
they're teaming up with Iran they're
teaming up with Saudi they're teaming up
with Russia they're teaming up with all
these other guys and everybody around
the country saying well the New World
Order 2.0 is those guys should we be
worried about it the video started off
with the first phrase I said was what
Andy Grove only the paranoid survive we
have to stay paranoid all the time
because as things like this have and if
you get two cocky and saying don't worry
about those guys they're not doing as
good as they think they're doing I
understand but also at the same time 75
of poker hands the winner wasn't the
best hand it's who could Bluff the best
and man G dude somebody send that man a
bracelet dude you're crushing it they're
gonna have to deal with this issue this
is not a good one and this is an issue
that's going to take a couple decades to
fix you know certain things in life
you're like may I put on 48 pounds you
can get off of your sweets or Coke or
bread and you'll lose the weight
eventually three six months you cannot
lose this weight in three to six months
you know how long this could take to fix
50 years this could take to fix 50 years
you know what it means it's 50 years of
husband and wife's having to spend time
in the bedroom for the next 10 years
just making babies left and right they
need to go bring the best r b songs to
China and these r b guys need to go out
and perform non-stop on the radio right
Sade needs to be on repeat baby cherish
the day right that's all they need to be
playing I want to stop here you get the
drift so if you got value from this
video and you're thinking and maybe I
got you a laugh as well give it a thumbs
up subscribe to the channel I did a
video titled 2023 predictions and I talk
about India and China if you've not seen
it this was shot in December of 2022
click here to watch it take care
everybody